una carrera contra el reloj mientras la
mitad de los habitantes todavía no
tienen electricidad el alcalde de la
ciudad acaba de expresar su gratitud a
los técnicos que restablecieron la
calefacción
quiero agradecerles a ustedes los 300
empleados de la compañía energética
templo de kiev ustedes quienes trabajan
día y noche gracias a ustedes podemos
anunciar hoy que el 97% de los hogares
tienen de nuevo calefacción las
temperaturas van bajando tener calor se
vuelve vital porque en Ucrania el
invierno está llegando y las
temperaturas han pasado bajo cero pero
Rusia sigue bombardeando las
infraestructuras civiles esenciales
dejando millones de ucranianos sin gas O
electricidad desde kiefa al norte hasta
odesal Sur desde las orillas del Bíper
al este hasta el VIP cerca de Polonia no
hago un llamamiento a todos por favor
hagan reservas de agua carguen sus
celulares piensen en las comunicaciones
Prepárense con sus familias en caso de
que caigan las conexiones
Esta es una foto del cielo ucraniano
tomada a principios de febrero por la
NASA y otra tomada este jueves
secundaciones unidas la falta de energía
en Ucrania este invierno podría llevar a
nuevos desplazamientos de la población
dentro de los cuales podría haber un
Éxodo afuera del país